and finally new rule this year just
celebrate Thanksgiving don't try to win
it I never forget the single shining
truth about democracy it means sharing a
country with [ __ ] you can't stand in
that way it's a lot like Thanksgiving
you don't get to choose the guests
because those freaks are your family
think about that the next time you think
you can own someone politically think
about how you can see politics so
differently from people who share your
very blood we have to accept something
about people half of them have their
taste in their ass they eat sweet
potatoes with marshmallows they wear
matching family outfits and put nuts on
their truck
they laugh at Jeff Dunham we laugh at
Lena Dunham 46 percent of the country
looked at this and said I want that guy
picking the Supreme Court we will never
understand a brain that thinks like that
and they will never understand worrying
about gluten all the time or a Puerto
Rican Alexander Hamilton that's how you
get two completely different headlines
about the same thing Jim Jordan destroys
dem star witness room erupts and
laughter as Democrat Peter Welch
destroys Jim Jordan we're so divided
it's no longer enough to just make a
point you have to destroy you have to
own people except the person who gets
owned doesn't change their mind they
just make a mental note never to
interact again with DM me your titties
[Applause]
we have to drop this fantasy that we can
destroy the other side or crush or shred
or pulverize them those aren't real
things they're the metal for settings on
the blender that no one has ever used
America is a big country filled with
millions of people who don't think the
way you do and never will and you can't
own Vanquish or disappear them we're
stuck with them
and they're stuck with us they're here
they're annoying get used to it because
because the pendulum always swings back
even when we had a civil war and
physically owned the south literally
burnt their cities to the ground and
occupied their territory reconstruction
only lasted for 12 years before the mint
julep crowd took over again and Jim Crow
the KKK and sharecropping became slavery
2.0 we tried to own the Germans after
World War one and that just got us World
War two now lately we've been hearing
more and more about a second civil war
which sounds impossible in this modern
affluent country it is not we all talk
about Trump as an existential threat but
his side sees Democratic control of
government the exact same way and when
both sides believe the other guy taking
over means the end of the world yes you
can't have a civil war Trump rallies are
filled with words like enemies of the
people human scum they talk of people to
be locked up
well you can't lock us all up liberals
are described as weak lame coddling
oversensitive and limp-dicked
which are strong words for a bunch of
mouth-breather shit-kickers
knuckle-draggers
[Music]
bible-thumpers sister [ __ ] and groups
yes I have been guilty of saying things
like that but I'm gonna try to stop
because I've learned that the anti
intellectualism on the right doesn't
come primarily from stupidity it comes
from hate telling people you think
they're irredeemable is what makes them
say you know what I'd rather side with
Russia than you even if the Democrats
win everything in 2020 the Republicans
will still be here they're not going to
self-deport they're in Congress in your
office
sometimes your home home is where you
learn that the three magic words in any
relationship aren't I love you
there let it go let it go you can't you
can't own your spouse you sometimes just
have to make peace with the fact that
you're married to someone who believes
in ghosts or won't throw out their
baseball cards or thinks essential oils
are essential or yes
likes Donald Trump we are going to have
to learn to live with each other or
there will be blood so don't freak out
if Ellen sits next to George Bush at a
football game Bush was not my idea of a
good president but I never worried that
he was going to lock up his political
opponents or reporters or me
bush was wrong but he wasn't trying to
enrich George Bush he condemned
Islamophobia after 9/11 and he did a lot
for aids in African countries without
calling them shitholes he risked Dick
Cheney's friendship because he wouldn't
parter pardon Scooter Libby because it
wasn't always just about loyalty he
stood with Obama when Obama took his job
and he said we want you to succeed if
you can't see the difference between
that and Trump Democrats are doomed
Michelle Obama gets it she hugs him Ruth
Bader Ginsberg likes Brett Kavanaugh for
a country that loves to look at pictures
of entirely different species getting
along can't we try it in politics
[Applause]
you